In this lecture,
we're going to be
talking about very
general aspects
of the musculoskeletal
system.
In part one, I'm just
going to give you
a basic introduction
to the lecture, and
then we're going to
talk about bones.
Before we get into
the content of
this lecture, I
thought it would be
valuable to go over
what you should
expect to learn
about the gross
anatomy of the
musculoskeletal system.
The musculoskeletal
system makes up a very
large component of the
body in terms of its
volume and mass. It
consists of your limbs,
the spine and back
muscles, and your body
wall, and the skull and
muscles of the head.
There are many,
many individual
structures in the
musculoskeletal system
that you should
expect to know.
Parts of the musculoskeletal
system include
bones, cartilage,
muscles, and other
connected tissues
such as ligaments and
fascia. In lectures
you will receive on
the gross anatomy
of components of the
musculoskeletal system,
there is no way to
go over all of the
individual structures.
Therefore, you should
study these in the
anatomy lab and on
your own. In addition
to studying and
recognizing the individual
structures, you
should focus on their
connections. In
particular, focus on the
bony attachments of
muscles and how this
affects what actions
the muscles cause.
And obviously, you
should be focusing
on joints, what
movements they allow
and what movements
they restrict.
Finally,
you should carefully
study how the
musculoskeletal
system interfaces
with the remainder
of the body. This
occurs primarily via
nerves and vasculature.
As you study the
musculoskeletal system,
one of your major
focuses should be on the
nerves that innervate
the muscles and the
main arteries and
veins that transport
blood to and from
different parts of the
musculoskeletal system.
As you will see
in later lectures,
an understanding of
muscle attachments and
actions, the innervations
of muscles and
the potential motions
allowed by joints are
a major part of the
clinical diagnosis of
musculoskeletal injuries
and pathologies.
Here are the session
objectives for
this lecture.
We will briefly
discuss the growth,
development, and morphology
of skeletal tissue.
We're going to go
over the main types of
synovial joints based
on types of motion.
We're going to briefly
touch upon types of
cartilage in their
distribution and the
different types of
muscle contractions and
how they contribute
to motion in the body.
Note the final
objective about muscle
contractions is typically
the most difficult for
many students to
understand. If you have
trouble with this
objective, do not hesitate
to contact me and I
will help you out.
Once you get it, it
will seem very simple.
Now for some basics
about the skeleton. The
skeleton consists of
two parts. The axial
skeleton, which is
brown in this figure,
consists of the skull,
spine, and the ribs. The
appendicular skeleton
is represented in
green and is the limbs,
including the pectoral
and pelvic girdles.
Bones of the skeleton
can be categorized in
one way by their shape.
For instance, bones
such as the femur and
the thigh are long and
slender and are called
long bones. While we
think of long bones
such as the femur as
an individual bone, it
really has many parts
that develop separately
and fuse together
into a single element.
These parts include
the diaphysis, which
is the shaft, and the
epiphyses, which are
the articular ends.
We will discuss the
development of a long one
later, a little later.
Short bones are
small and blocky.
Most are found
in your hand.
You have
encountered this,
they're most found
in your hand.
The word manis,
which you may have
encountered before, is
a Latin term for hand.
And you've heard
this word before,
such as in the
word manuscript,
which means
handwritten, or manual
labor, which means
work with the hands.
The Latin term
for foot, which is
pez, is used less
frequently, but you'll
encounter that
word as well. It's
derived from the
Latin word petal.
Many of the bones
in the skull and
other bones, such
as the scapula, are
flat bones. Then
you have a lot of
miscellaneous bones
with irregular shapes,
such as your vertebra.
Finally, there
are numerous bones
embedded in tendons.
Your patella,
otherwise known as
your kneecap, is
the largest example
of one of these.
these are called
sesamoid bones and then
finally as you will
see in later slides the
shapes of the bones
has a lot to do with
the different ways that
they actually develop
all bones even flat
bones are composed
of basically two types
of bones all bones
are surrounded by a
dense solid superficial
layer of compact bone
this compact bone
can also be called
cortical bone deep to
the compact bone the
cavity within is filled
by a very porous
spongy bone depending
on the mechanical
loads of the bone the
compact bone can be very
thick or thin and it
can vary consider
considerably along the
length of the bone even
very thin flat bones
such as the scapula
have thin layers of
both compact and
spongy bone as I noted
earlier the shapes
of bones are strongly
related to how they
develop embryologically.
So bones are derived
from two basic processes.
The first of these
is intramembranous
bone. These bones
ossify directly from or
within membranes formed
by an embryological
connective tissue
known as mesenchyme.
Consequently, they
are flat and membrane
-shaped. Typical examples
of intramembranous bone
would be the bones of
your brain cake, such
as your patella or
your temporal bone. The
second type of bones
are endochondral bones.
They ultimately are
derived by mesenchyme
also, but they start
out being preformed by
cartilage, which gradually
ossifies into bone
as the person becomes
an adult. Long bones
are typical examples
of endochondral bone.
Other examples of
endochondral bone are
like what you see here
on the bottom right,
the blocky bones in
your manis and pez,
the carpals and the
tarsals. As a general
rule, any bone that
takes place in a
synovial joint is going
to be endochondral.
It's important to
realize that bones
consist of many parts
that develop separately
and fuse together
into a single bone.
Therefore, bones can
have intramembranous and
endochondral parts
in the same bone. The
scapula is a good
example. The flat body is
intramembranous, but
several parts along the
margins are endochondral,
and these are shown
in blue. Note the
glenoid cavity, which
takes part in the shoulder
joint and articulates
with the humerus,
is clearly part of a
synovial joint, that of
the shoulder joint, and
it is an endochondral
part of the scapula.
All bones are covered
by a thin membrane
known as periosteum. You
won't study periosteum
closely in gross
anatomy, but it is there
nonetheless, and it's
very important to
bone biology, so you
should know about it.
The articular
surfaces of bones are
the only surfaces
that are not
covered by periosteum.
All other bone
surfaces are covered
by periosteum.
Periosteum is vascularized,
so it provides
nutrients to the outer
layers of the bone.
And then osteoprogenitor
cells in the
periosteum deposit bone
and enable bone growth.
Periosteum is
involved in how
tendons and ligaments
attach to bone.
And periosteum is
richly innervated
with sensory nerves.
and much of the
intense somatic pain
that, for example,
would be associated
with a broken bone is
related to damage
to the periosteum.
I mentioned that the
blood is applied to
the superficial layers
of bone as through
the periosteum. Deep
layers are supplied by
arteries that pierce
the bone and run more
deeply into it. The
openings for these
blood vessels are called
nutrient foramina.
Nutrient foramina are
macroscopic and can
readily be seen when
you study dry bones.
By the way, every
ossification center of a
bone needs at least
one nutrient foramen,
so bones that are
composed of several fused
elements have multiple
nutrient foramina.
Long bones are the
largest bones in
your body, and their
growth is important
for physical
attributes such as
body height and body
proportions. It's
therefore important
to have a basic
understanding of
how long bones grow.
In this sequence of
the humerus, starting
on the left, the bone
begins as a cartilage
model derived from
mesenchyme. As we
move to the right,
the shaft of the bone,
which as I said before
is called the diaphesus,
begins to ossify first,
and the epiphyses,
which are the ends
of the bones, lag
behind. Notice in figure
four in the middle
of the slide that
the epiphyses may
actually have multiple
centers of ossification.
As the majority of
the bone becomes
ossified in figure five,
lengthwise growth of
the diaphesus continues
in the cartilaginous
space between the
diaphysis and the
epiphysis. So that
would be here and here.
This is the region
where lengthwise
growth continues, and
this is called the
epiphyseal plate. A
bone fracture involving
the epiphyseal
plate in a subadult
is potentially
serious, as damage to
the epiphyseal plate
can cause interruption
of lengthwise
growth of the bone.
Figure 6 on the
right is an adult
bone. The epiphyseal
plate is fully
ossified. At this
point, lengthwise growth
of the bone is no
longer possible,
and the lengths of
the bones and, for
example, your body
height have become fixed.
In an x-ray of an
adult, an epiphyseal
line is sometimes still
visible right here
and distally right here,
where the diaphysis
and the epiphysis
are fused together.
Here's an example of
the x-rays of the limbs
of a neonate. As you
can see, large parts
of the skeleton are
not visible as they
are still unossified.
The carpals and tarsals
are mostly unossified.
The diaphyses of
most long bones are
present, but the epiphyses
are largely unossified.
It is therefore
difficult to examine
the joints because
they are mostly
cartilaginous at this point.
In the next
slide, we have an
example of an 8
-year-old hand x
-ray compared to
that of an adult.
For many of the finger
bones, the diaphyses
and epiphyses are
distinctly different
bones. The carpels
are also still only
partially ossified.
The skeleton of
juveniles is very
different from that of
adults, as you can
see. not only in its
appearance, but in its
material properties
because it contains
much more cartilage.
Any area of pediatric
medicine that concerns
itself with growth
and development of
children will
require a very good
understanding of the
ontogeny of the skeleton.
However, we will
not study juvenile
osteology in detail
here. Nonetheless, you
should be able to
recognize the various
parts of a long bone
in a pediatric x-ray.
as you study bones
you will notice that
they do not have
regular smooth surfaces
bones have irregular
surfaces with what at
first appear to be
seemingly randomly
distributed bumps rough
areas concavities and
protuberances these
surface features are
the attachment sites
of tendons ligaments
and other structures
that attach to bone
make sure you study
the surface anatomy of
bones as you will be
required to be familiar
with many of these
features Any anatomy
textbook should have
a basic table with
the terminology of
surface bone anatomy.
In part two of this
lecture, we will go
over some basics about
cartilage and its
distribution in the
body, and we will
cover the different
types of joints, and
more specifically,
talk about synovial
joints and how they
can be classified
according to their
potential movements.
There are three types of
cartilages. cartilages.
These three types
have different
histologies, and this
relates directly to
their different
material properties.
Hyaline cartilage is
the most common type
of cartilage. It is
semi-flexible, and
here on the left
you can see the
histology of hyaline
cartilage. It consists
of chondrocytes in
a homogenous matrix.
Fiber cartilage on
the top right is a
much tougher, more
rigid type of cartilage.
It contains fibers
visible in the
cartilage matrix that
make it much stronger
and tougher than
hyaline cartilage.
Finally, on the
lower right is an
example of elastic
cartilage. It contains
bundles of
elastin, which are
stained purple here,
and gives this type
of cartilage
extreme flexibility.
Elastic cartilage
resists being damaged
by being extremely
compliant. However,
it has very little
strength or rigidity,
and so it is not
a strong material.
This figure highlights
the distribution
of the three types
of cartilage. You
should study the
distribution of cartilages
and be able to
recognize which of
the three types of
cartilage a particular
cartilaginous
structure is made of.
Highline cartilage shown
in blue is the
most common.
Endochondral bone begins
as highline cartilage
before it ossifies
and becomes fully
ossified bones in adults.
In an adult skeleton,
highline cartilage is
located in synovial
joints, costal
cartilages, and the
cartilages in the pharynx
and bronchial tree.
Elastic cartilages,
shown in
green, are the
flimsy cartilages,
such as the
oracle of the ear.
And finally,
fibrocartilages, which
are in red, form the
vertebral discs in
the spine and also
some other specialized
cartilages, such
as the menisci
in the knee and the
***** symphysis.
As you study
musculoskeletal anatomy,
joints are obviously
a focal point.
Joints are areas
where musculoskeletal
structures are
joined in complex
ways to permit and
restrict motion.
Joint injuries and
joint degeneration
are significant
concerns in medicine.
Joints consist of many
parts, including the
proximal and distal
ends of the bones,
the articular cartilages,
and other cartilaginous
structures in the
joints, such as
the fibrocartilaginous
menisci in the knee.
Joints are held together
by ligaments, as
you can see in the
top right figure, but
also by muscles that
cross these joints,
which are not pictured
here. The strength,
mobility, and motions
permitted by a
joint are determined
by several variables.
These include the
shapes of the articular
surfaces, which determine
which directions
the joint can
move. The ligaments
determine how much a
joint can bend in some
directions and prevent
excess movements
beyond that range. And
in other directions,
ligaments completely
prevent movement.
Muscles move the
joints, but they also
act as dynamic ligaments
and also determine
how much a joint
can bend and prevent
excess movements
beyond that range.
Joints have complex
vasculature.
Anastomoses, which
you will study in
detail later, are
basically redundant
blood supplies. The
same Joint tissues can
be supplied by numerous
arteries, which
assure that blood
moves to the joint
and to the tissues
beyond the joint, no
matter what position
the joint is in.
Basically anastomoses
around joints prevent
a highly flexed joint
from cutting off
blood supply to itself
and distal body parts.
Finally, joint
structures are richly
innervated.
The tendons and
ligaments are highly
sensitive to the
tension being
exerted upon them.
This contributes
to something
called proprioception,
which is the
ability of a person
to sense what
position their
body parts are in.
Proprioception is an
important sense as it
contributes to motor
abilities, such as
touching your nose with
your eyes, typing without
looking at your fingers,
or walking up and
down stairs without
looking at your feet.
There's an easy
shortcut to understand
which nerves
innervate which
joints. It's known
as Hilton's Law.
John Hilton is a famous
British surgeon who
first noted what we
now call Hilton's Law.
Hilton's Law says that
the nerve supplying
the muscles extending
directly across
and acting at a
given joint not only
supplies the muscle,
but also innervates the
joint and the skin
overlying the muscle.
Since you will be
studying the attachments,
innervations,
and actions of
muscles, you will
be able to use that
knowledge to infer
which nerves contribute
to the innervation
of associated joint
structures. So, no
need to memorize.
There are three types
of joints in the
body. We have already
discussed synovial
joints a little. They
are the most common
joint in the body and
are capable of the
most movement and the
most diverse kinds of
movement. All synovial
joints are enclosed
in a synovial capsule,
which is filled
with a lubricant
called synovial fluid,
and the articular
surfaces of the bones
are capped with
articular cartilages. We
will study synovial
joints in more detail.
On the upper right,
fibrous joints
are the sutures
in the skull.
These are immobile
or minimally mobile.
Syndysmosis are a
type of fibrous joint
that has the potential
for more motion.
The example here
is the interosseous
membrane between the
ulna and radius in
the forearm, which
allows the radius to
rotate about the
ulna. The lower right
shows two types of
cartilaginous joints.
Primary cartilaginous
joints, which
are also called
synchondroses,
are the joints
between the diaphyses
and the epiphyses
of long bones.
Primary cartilaginous
joints are not mobile.
These bones fuse
with age, and primary
cartilaginous joints are
not present in adults.
On the other hand,
secondary cartilaginous
joints do persist in
adults. The most common
examples of cartilaginous
joints are the
vertebral discs, which
allow limited motion.
You will receive an
entire lecture on the
anatomy of synovial
joints, so we will not
cover that here.
However, you should be
familiar with the basic
components of a synovial
joint, including the
joint capsule, which
surrounds and seals
the synovial capsule,
the synovial membrane,
which secretes
synovial fluid, and the
articular cartilage on
the proximal and distal
ends of the bone.
And now let's move
on to joint motion.
If you're not familiar
with the different
types of motions,
please review them
using this figure or
some other resources.
One helpful aspect of
the musculoskeletal
system is that you can
use your own body as
a cheat sheet to help
you study and understand
the motions of each
joint. There is no
harm in moving a joint
or palpating part of
your musculoskeletal
system during a test.
Most of the
musculoskeletal system is
observable through
its motions, surface
anatomy, and palpation.
As you study the
musculoskeletal system,
study the anatomy
of your own body
through these means
because with practice,
it will become your
most useful study
guide and reference.
You are naturally
already familiar with
the flexion and
extension capabilities
of most joints, but
there are aspects of
motion that you
may not have ever
recognized. As an
example, try and evaluate
the ability of the
knee joint to rotate.
Can the knee
rotate? Are there
a limited number
of positions
during which
this is possible?
Tenovial joints can
be classified by the
types of motions they
allow. In this example,
there is at least
one of each type of
joint. I've arranged
them on the left in
order from the least
mobile plane joint
to the most mobile
ball and socket joint.
Plane joints are
capable of some
small amounts of
gliding and sliding.
Most other joint
types are highly
mobile in some
directions, but not
others. For example,
hinge joints can
flex and extend,
but cannot abduct,
adduct, rotate,
or circumduct.
The most mobile
joint is the
ball and socket
joint, which is
capable of
flexion, extension,
abduction,
adduction, rotation,
and circumduction.
The knee, which we
mentioned earlier, is
a special kind
of joint called a
trochoginglimus, meaning
that it can flex and
extend, and also
rotate about an axis.
Again, you can
discover the motions
of joints by
examining yourself.
No need to memorize.
Try to deduce
what motions the
metacarpophalangeal
joints are capable of.
In Part 3 of
this lecture, we
will cover muscles
and the different
types of muscle
contractions.
It is pointless to
know the name and
anatomical location
of a muscle
without knowing its
associated detachments
and the primary
action that the
muscle produces
when it contracts.
Secondly, it is important
to have familiarity
with the innervations
of muscles,
as the evaluation of
muscle function and
muscle impairments is
a means of diagnosing
neurological injuries
and disorders.
There are some
convenient shortcuts
to learning the
innervations of muscles
of the limbs,
which will actually
make this quite
easy. We will cover
these shortcuts in
subsequent lectures.
Please note that
a muscle name
includes its bellies
and its tendons.
So when I refer
to, for instance,
the biceps brachii,
I am referring to
its long and short
heads and its proximal
and distal tendons.
You should be able
to recognize and know
the names of the
individual bellies of
major muscles that have
multiple bellies or
heads. For example,
as I mentioned, the
biceps brachi has
two bellies, the long
and short. They have
different attachments
and cause non-identical
sets of actions.
The name of the
muscle sometimes
offers major clues
to some aspect
of its anatomy.
For instance,
the adductor
pollicis reveals that
the muscle adducts
the thumb. This
is a helpful shortcut for
remembering or deducing
muscle actions.
Generally speaking,
the term contraction in
physiology refers to a
shortening or tensing
of an organ, especially
muscles. However,
this is a poor and
erroneous definition in
reference to muscles and
often causes confusion
about what a muscle
contraction really is.
When we study muscles
and muscle function,
please strike any
concept of shortening
or decreasing length
from your understanding
of the term
contraction. A muscle
contraction is the
activation of muscle fibers
resulting in the
generation of tension.
Nothing other than
the generation
of tension is
required for
a muscle contraction
to occur.
While we might think
of a muscle contraction
as leading to a
shortening of the muscle,
this is not always
the case. A length
change, either shortening
or elongating, may
occur, but it is not
required during a
muscle contraction.
For example, you may
attempt to lift a weight.
If the weight is too
heavy to lift, a
muscle contraction will
have taken place, but
if no movement has
taken place, the muscle
has not shortened.
Having cleared that
up, let's now look
at what the action
of a muscle is.
When you read
anatomy textbooks,
muscles are described
as having actions.
The action of a muscle
is what happens when
the muscle contracts
without resistance and
it produces a movement.
To use the biceps
brakii example again,
when it contracts without
resistance, it causes
the elbow to flex.
The action of the
triceps brakii,
on the other
hand, when it
contracts with
no resistance,
causes the
elbow to extend.
However, in real
life, muscles do not
work in isolation and
without resistance.
The biceps and the
triceps are antagonists.
In other words, they
move the elbow in the
opposite directions
and if they contract at
the same time will work
against one another.
There are also external
forces that muscles
must both combat and
cooperate with, such
as the force of gravity
pulling on the body,
gravity pulling on
other objects that
someone may be
attempting to interact
with, or the
resistance of another
person, such as a
wrestling opponent.
Consequently,
as you will see,
muscles do not
always shorten when
they contract, and
they do not always
produce their
textbook actions.
Walking down stairs is
a classic example of
muscles counteracting
gravity using eccentric
contractions of the
quadriceps muscles.
So at this point,
let's go over the major
types of muscle
contractions. On the
left, Arnold Schwarzenegger
is just standing
there, not moving,
but his muscles are
in a state of tonus.
Tonus is the condition
of your muscles
constantly being in an
involuntary state of
minor contraction.
Tonus is involuntary
and always occurs,
although it diminishes
during REM sleep.
We will not discuss tonic
contractions further.
In the middle
photo, Arnold is
demonstrating an
isometric contraction.
The flexors of his
elbow, including his
biceps brachii, and the
extensor, the triceps
brachii, are contracting
in equilibrium
and holding his elbow
in an unmoving state
of stasis. As long
as his elbow is in
the same position, the
muscles do not change
length, although they
are still contracting,
so during an
isometric contraction,
the length of the
muscles do not change.
In the right
photo, Arnold is
working out with
a weight machine.
His elbow is going
through cycles
of extending and
flexing, and the
extensor muscles
in his arm are
changing length with
each contraction.
These are isotonic
contractions.
There are
further two types
of isotonic contractions.
Concentric contractions
are where the
muscles shorten, and
eccentric contractions
are where the
muscle elongates.
It sounds highly
counterintuitive that
a muscle can elongate
while it contracts
because a muscle
can only pull in
one direction. It
cannot push. But I
hope to explain this
in further slides.
In this scenario,
a weightlifter is
lifting and lowering
a weight. weight.
This exercise involves
repeated flexion
and extension of
the elbow against
a constant extrinsic
force, in this
case the pull of
gravity on the weight,
which continually pulls
downward a
constant amount.
Even though the elbow
is both flexing and
extending in this
exercise, bodybuilders
are well aware that
the exercise works
the biceps brachi
but does absolutely
nothing for the triceps.
The triceps does
nothing here, while the
biceps controls both
the up and down
movement of the weight.
How can it be that
the biceps brakii
and other flexor
muscles of the elbow
control both flexion
and extension
and the triceps
brakii plays no role?
In phase one of
this exercise,
the biceps brakii
and other flexor
muscles of the
elbow contract.
The contraction is
sufficiently powerful to
overcome the force of
gravity on the weight.
The flexor muscles
shorten and the weight
is lifted. This is a
concentric contraction.
In phase two, the
weight must be
lowered at a slow,
controlled rate. The
gravitational pull
on the weight can
extend the arm without
muscular input.
The triceps is
therefore not needed
to extend the arm
in this situation.
As noted, the weight
must be lowered slowly.
Moreover, the
triceps can offer no
assistance in slowing
the rate that the arm
is extended since
it can only work in
the same direction
as the weight itself.
You might conclude
that the flexor
muscles of the arm
must relax to lower
the weight. But this
is not the case.
If the flexor
muscles relaxed, the
weight would fall
suddenly and rapidly.
Again, the weight must
be lowered slowly.
The flexor muscles must
continue to contract,
but with a force
that is slightly less
than the gravitational
pull of the weight.
In this scenario,
the weight is slowly
lowered and the
elbow is extended.
due to the
controlled resistance
of the flexor
muscles, which
included the
biceps brachi.
The muscle is
activated, but the
weight is forcing
it to be elongated.
This is an eccentric
contraction.
This is easy to
understand if
you compare it
to a tug-of-war.
Muscles are
continuously in a tug
-of-war battle with
opposing forces.
Gravity is a constant
opposing force. In
a tug-of-war battle
with gravity, in this
scenario the muscle
overpowers gravity.
The muscle shortens
and the muscle wins.
During an eccentric
contraction, gravity
and muscles are opposing
one another, but
in this case gravity
is more powerful.
Gravity pulls the
muscle with a force
that exceeds the force
of the contraction.
In some cases, the
force may simply
be more powerful
than the full
potential of the
muscle to resist.
However, in most
circumstances, the
muscle is allowing
gravity to win on purpose
by exerting a
contractile force against
gravity that
controls the rate of
movement in the direction
that is opposite
of the primary
action of the muscle.
An eccentric contraction
always involves
movement in the
direction that is
in the opposite of
the primary action
of the muscle. So,
for example, if
a concentric contraction
of a particular
muscle causes
flexion of a joint,
An eccentric
contraction of the
same muscle will
always involve
extension of
the same joint.
Because gravity is a
constant force, day
-to-day movement of
the human body will
always involve a complex
mixture of concentric
and eccentric
contractions. As you study
muscles and their
primary actions, it
would be a good idea
to explore how use of
those muscles might
involve concentric and
eccentric contractions.
So, for instance,
you might ask
yourself what exercise
could one do that
involves both flexion and
extension of the elbow
with contractions
of the biceps, of
the triceps brachi.
So a push-up is a good
example of another
simple exercise that
uses the triceps brachi
that involves a
mixture of concentric
and eccentric contractions
of the triceps
brachi. On your own
time, consider the
position of the elbow
during the up phase
and down phase of a
push-up. What kinds
of contractions of
the triceps brachii
were involved to
reach each point? It's
easiest to remember
that an eccentric
contraction is always
the opposite movement
of the primary
action of the muscle.